The joe rogan experience.
That's the one thing comics left to do.
We love being children dot.
Barron's Tom viruses like that,
king of that shit.
I was talking to him last night about you.
He loves you to death and he's like,
you should bring it up.
But how he used to,
he used to go on the road with you or did you dawn?
I would put don in whatever I was in,
I would put him in,
like,
we wound up doing this,
this crazy frank Stallone movie in Ixtapa,
you know,
uh,
Mexico and we were stuck there for like five weeks.
And of course I made,
I made dawn do like Alfred Hitchcock and the movie,
there was no call for Alfred Hitchcock,
but I talked to producers into it,
you know,
and that's where he actually hurt,
hurt his foot.
You know how he's got like a bad foot.
Yeah,
he hurt his foot.
Well,
what happened with don?
He always wants to fight me,
you know,
so,
so one day,
you know,
he starts in with me on the set and it's all these Mexican crew members that
don't even understand English.
And he puts his foot like there was a hole in the ground and he wouldn't cut at
a hospital after to fix it,
you know?
So to this day,
like he just moves the wrong way and he's crippled,
you know,
he just falls down and,
and it was funny,
what happened was I went back to a Madison Square Garden in 2000 and it was
Don's job at the time to come there because he really wants to see it with my
wife and my sons.
So he was the problem on the plane because what happened was he's walking down
an aisle and the foot goes and he,
you know,
Don's emotional,
so he's screaming,
laying on the floor and Blaine scaring,
scaring the entire flight,
you know,
and then they get them into a chair and the foot felt better.
You know,
that the cops were at the airport to question him and I go,
you a job was to just bring them.
He had,
that was the gift.
You get to fly for nothing and get a hotel room,
bring them in and you cause a problem on the fucking airline.
But that's done.
You know,
that's who he is.
Do you think he was his practical joking with,
you know,
he was
laying at norms.
No Nigga,
I'm going,
it really goes,
his foot really goes,
is it a broken foot?
Is it a ligament?
I'm sure he'd like chips,
something in his ankle and he just wouldn't go to the house.
He goes,
well they're going to do to me,
you know,
he turns into this baby,
you know?
Oh yeah.
And he would do the road with me,
you know,
and I had it when he would do the road with,
I would just take them with me when he would do the road.
I had a,
at that time I had Eddie Griffin with me.
I had,
yeah.
So Eddie Griffin was like the real open,
you know.
And so what would happen is I give don 10 minutes right upfront.
So we'd be on a big tour bus,
traveling the country and one time he's on the bus and he's like,
you know how he gets down on himself,
you know,
like almost like that,
that he's not crying with tears.
But I'm going well down.
It's because the crowd doesn't respond the way he wants.
You know,
cause he would come out singing,
tie a yellow ribbon,
you know,
you know with the,
with the music over it and get the crowd clapping.
And so now the song ends and then he goes into another one.
I'll go into like Copa Cabana.
So now he's on the bus complaining about that.
Go Don,
it's you a 10 minutes after they get the joke of who you are that you're this
fucking goofball.
Well now we are the jokes,
you know.
And he would go,
well,
you know,
I went into the other,
so I go,
they don't want to hear another,
you already did the bit,
you had them clap.
Now they've got to clap to Barry Manilow singing,
you know,
Copa Cabana,
who gives a fuck,
you know what I mean?
And nobody gives a fuck.
You create the character,
you just fucking big goofball and now give him jokes,
you know?
And,
but we had a lot of fun and then there would be another rumble on the bus.
Now it's him jumping on me and trying to kill me on the bus.
Yeah.
He's,
his life is constant theater with that guy.
Did I?
That's who I hang out with every single day from midnight to about 4:00 AM Tom
Barrett.
That's fun.
And you know,
it was hysterical with the movie we did in Ixtapa,
uh,
they,
they want them to stay and film for longer than I,
I want them to be there,
you know,
and I'm going,
I gotta get Outta here.
I got gigs I got to do.
So they promised me a lot of,
a lot of money,
you know,
in like cash and in Taiwan,
through the whole shoot is going,
they're never giving it to you.
You've got to get it now.
I go,
Don,
they're going to pay me.
We made a deal.
That's it.
You know,
Eh,
you know,
and you know,
the,
it was a crazy set,
you know,
I mean,
I never went through anything like this in a film ever.
You know,
what went on in those five weeks.
And so he's gone,
you know,
two to five weeks.
I've got to hear how they're not going to pay me.
You know,
he's just on me that the,
and of course they give me the money and dawn had a tape it up,
you know,
all over my body.
Like that movie midnight express.
Did you really?
Yeah,
because you know,
it was a part of Mexico that we actually thought that the director was going to
happen.
He stopped at the airport,
you know,
so you know with thinking,
all right,
how am I gay?
Cause she not allowed more than like $10,000 in cash and it was a lot of money,
you know,
so he was taping it with this like paper tape to my chest to my thought.
You know that when I got home and when we're going through the airport,
I'm gone,
they're going to stop me,
I'm going to be in jail and whoever stops and he's going to be rich,
you know,
it's that simple.
But they didn't stop us.
And now I get home and I take off my shirt and my wife sees all this money taped
to my chest and she's going,
what is that?
You know,
and I'm going,
no,
they paid me.
You know,
that's how they pay you in Mexico.
But Dom was just so sure.
Then I pay me for them.
It was just crazy.
It was,
I wouldn't eat,
we only had one meal a day because everybody on the set was getting sick.
You know,
everybody was going to the hospital and it,
and all we had every day was um,
we went to the same restaurant about four o'clock every day.
We had pasta with sauce,
garlic bread and Coca Cola with purified ice.
And we would eat til the next day at the same time.
Cause we figured we'd make it the middle of the day because we're only getting
that one meal.
We're not eating any of the food there.
Wow.
Yeah.
And he lost like 30 pounds.
Fine.
He's,
he's gone.
I got to eat something,
you know,
he's going,
this is ridiculous.
We're not eating food,
you know,
but everybody's fallen at the waist side.
What are we going to do?
We got no choice.
This is survival,
my friend.
Would those be movie sets can be very fucking sketchy.
And it was for a long time,
was hit five weeks of the same food.
But I'm a cringe Mexico.
I could do that.
I could eat the same thing every single day,
but you want it like twice a day.
But the restaurant,
we're close like nine at night,
so we'd have to wait till the next day at four o'clock to have the next meal.
Wow.
So it was bottled water,
you know,
and that was it.
Bottled water and pasta once a day.
What's the name of it was called the good life.
It never came out.
Ah.
You know,
and I always talked to frank Stallone.
He always says he should release like pieces of it on the Internet.
Yeah.
It was the craziest thing,
you know?
Uh,
I wanted it to be a comedy.
Frank Stallone wanted it to be a drama,
you know,
because,
I would tell the producers,
I go,
you know,
it's really a funny movie,
and comedy cells.
So when frank would do a scene,
he'd come over to the director and go,
you know,
how was that?
And he goes,
well,
it was very dramatic,
you know,
and he's gone,
well,
it's supposed to be a drama.
And he goes,
well,
I think it should be funnier.
And he goes,
put the movies a fucking drama.
Like,
so he was flipping out it.
We had a big fight over that movie.
But uh,
but the producers now wanted to just be like a comedy.
Dennis Hopper's in it.
It was supposed to be,
you know what it was supposed to be.
It was supposed to be Goodfellas on a golf course.
So Dennis Hopper,
you,
Dennis Hopper was in it,
but it was filming.
Really.
Can you find it anywhere?
It's snow would be,
but it doesn't.
Yeah.
It's not online,
but no one put it online.
But David Carradine was in it too.
Yeah.
A lot of people were in is really the Angelos alone,
isn't it?
Yes.
That's hilarious.
He didn't never made it.
You should never know shit to Netflix or something like that.
You make,
it's,
well,
it's not my movie to sell,
but you know,
it just wound up the whole time in Ixtapa was drama,
you know?
But the movie's hysterical.
You know,
it was just movie sets.
I've only been on one.
I've been on,
well to be movie.
But you know what happened?
We had a good director at the beginning and then the producer who was an
attorney fired the director and he'd decided to direct a no.
So now what happens is,
this is where it starts going a little crazy.
Uh,
and I,
you know,
I can't play golf.
I hate fucking golf.
I don't have patience to hit a one little ball,
you know,
of course the pork,
whatever,
you know.
So I wasn't really good at playing the golf,
you know,
so we would make it that they make fun of me.
But I had some like golf material at the time.
We had talked about hating golf.
So the,
the,
this new director makes me do some of that material on like the master shot,
like on a crane.
So he goes,
I want you to do that monologue every time,
you know?
And I go,
no,
but I'm not doing that monologue every time I did a few,
cause you asked me to do it in the mass to shut just so he gets them talking and
he goes,
no,
I want you to do it.
I go,
that's my material from my act.
I don't want to do it.
You know you're not paying me for it all year.
And he goes,
you'll do what I say.
I know I'm not going to do a fucking thing.
You say,
I go and don't ever tell me what to do again.
Ever in front of the camera.
Which Dom Barris is falling down laughing as he's making a little documentary
movie with my camera,
because I was always filming.
He did.
He literally say,
you'll do as I say,
yeah,
whoever lands.
And he goes and he,
and he says,
if you don't like it,
you could leave.
So I said,
okay,
I'll leave.
I go done.
Let's go.
And I had clipped soda,
Kenny,
they,
I go,
let's say.
He goes,
well,
my attorneys will be in touch.
I go,
asshole,
you told me to leave to say it.
You don't want me in the movie,
if I don't want to do my own material and I don't want to do it,
so don't fucking tell me what to do and I'll stay and that's it.
You know?
And what don loved is,
no matter what the guy did,
you know,
for his main profession,
he goes,
you're telling you director,
the guy that's supposed to tell you what to do,
don't ever tell me what to do again,
but that's his only job right now is telling you what to do.
I go,
yeah,
but you heard what?
When went down,
you know,
and he agreed with it.
And then I decided to direct part of the special,
it's not the special the movie.
And um,
cause I come to the set one day and it's like 110 degrees.
And this guy,
you know,
the guy directing was,
he had a funny character.
He was very low keyed with a sombrero cause it was Mexico and it was always hot.
And I go,
uh,
what are we doing today?
And he goes,
I don't know.
You know,
and I go,
do you want me to set the shot up?
And he goes,
what'd you please?
This is the director now.
He goes,
just tapped out.
I just want to finish the movie and go home.
And that's how he would talk.
That's like an impression of the guy.
So now I'm directing,
I'm directing the movie.
And that was a scene I directed.
This was great because I was like a little at wool with frank stuff at the time
on the set.
So I was shooting a scene that I needed dawn Barris for and now I decided to
club soda.
Kenny will be in the movie also,
you know.
So frank is shooting a scene where he's like playing a guitar in his underwear,
talking to some girl he was with in bed the night before.
So I come in there and I take the sound guys,
I'm like,
come on,
just come with me.
So now I get the sound guy.
So he winds up shooting this whole scene that he's doing and he doesn't know,
he doesn't have sound.
And all of a sudden coming from this house,
you hear him screaming,
he talked the fucking sound,
guys,
you made me do all these takes and we don't even have fucking sound.
And then the director's going,
well,
diocese directing a scene right now,
you know?
And he goes,
why the fuck is he directing anything?
It's not his movie to direct.
I mean,
people were having,
and then we crashed the golf carts,
which I got in trouble for.
I play chicken with the,
you know,
Peter Dobson,
he's an actor.
No.
Um,
he's been in a lot of stuff anyway,
so it's an Ian Dobson.
We're good friends and decide to play chicken with the golf carts.
And I turn it the last second and my golf cart gets completely destroyed.
And frank goes flying out of it because he's with me going,
what are you doing as what?
Going towards each other and I'm going to just stick with me on this.
He goes,
I don't want to stick with you.
Stopped driving,
you know,
but we wouldn't stop driving.
And I turned and they smash him.
I,
so now I'm not allowed to.
You play golf cart chicken.
Yeah.
Chicken to see who turns first,
you know,
and then we're having sword fights with the golf clubs.
I mean,
it was ridiculous.
What was going on.
You know,
Beverly Deangelo's in the movie,
uh,
Frank Pash is in the move towards your war with a frank Stallone.
What was it?
Just that I believe the movie should be a comedy,
you know?
So I started doing like an impression of him on screen goes,
I could do him really well the way he stands and Oh,
you know,
so now he sees the final cut and he goes,
what are you doing behind me?
You know,
I go an impression of you.
He goes,
you're not supposed to be doing an impression of me.
I'm,
I'm the leader of the gang I got,
but it's funny.
And he goes to put the movie's not funny,
you know?
And of course we all made up after them,
you know,
movie,
never came out,
you know,
make up with everybody.
Make up with Paul.
You may not put that guy.
Yeah.
Because it's,
it's more fun to have your friends.
Are you going to make them laugh about it?
Yeah.